[Music]
hey Luke here at the Agora boys YouTube
channel it's a cold fall day and that
means it's time for more forging videos
and today were forging the squirrel
blade
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I just bet my thumbnail backwards
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go no warping can't see any
cracks I might have pulled this off well
last night after I put my Forge away I
realized I made a big mistake I need to
drill at least two holes into the tang
of this knife
traditionally you do that before you
harden this deal we're gonna go ahead
and try to drill the holes into the
tempered steel of the Tang we're gonna
see how that goes it'll be an adventure
punch the hole easiest pie through this
end can't even make a dent down here
that's bad from a [ __ ]
there we go three holes here's the
beautiful piece of King wood and I've
been saving this for a special project
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
look at that knife that just turned out
awesome absolutely love the handle love
the feel of the blade and that sheet can
you get any cooler when I started to
scroll blade project I thought there's a
little bit of a joke okay this is the
coolest knife sheath ever I love this
now some of you might be wondering is
this a concealed weapon because it's a
knife hidden inside a squirrel aha
but this is where being a criminal
defense attorney really pays off here in
Virginia as long as it's a single edged
knife without a clip point it doesn't
get classified under the concealed
weapons laws so I can safely legally and
fashionably concealed carry the squirrel
blade hey Curtis you want crown squirrel
blade yeah
best knife ever or awesomest knife ever
awesomest manliest cuz it makes my voice
deep like this too oh oh oh
squirrel blades a powerful thing hey
baby you like my squirrel blade like me
I hope you enjoyed this video if you
want to see the full squirrel hunting
catch and cook video check out the link
in the description if you want to see
our foraging playlist check that out
I'll put a link in the description and
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new videos every Saturday morning
thanks for watching your eyes if you
like this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor Boise
we have hundreds of videos just like
this and don't forget to click subscribe
so you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that belt like
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching do you want a squirrel blade
with your bigger